but right now I mean I'm kind of like
running on all cylinders I'm willing to
take on quite a quite a range of people
but um well you think a lot about it
wolf pack of one or small yeah wolf pack
as opposed to having like a New York
Times behind you or a huge organizations
with lawyers with a team with the
history with these people are less
courageous this is the this is the dirty
truth the bigger the organization the
more conservative a lot of them are it's
true that sometimes they like and this
is not to bash big organizations I'm
just saying this is an observation of
someone who's talked to a lot of people
and especially in the world of fraud a
lot of them are scared to engage
in fraud that is obvious but hasn't been
litigated yet this is why you'll never
see documentaries about ongoing fraud on
Netflix it's too much of a liability
they'll Sue Netflix to hell and they
know that if they win Netflix has the
money to pay it so corporations like the
New York Times you know a lot of these
some of them are very Cur like they're
as courageous as they can be but at the
bottom line if someone sues you to hell
and back and you have to pay up you will
disappear and you're relying on
liability insurance which you're already
paying out the ask for to try to cover
you if you get sued but if you get sued
even if you win that liability insurance
now goes up in price the next year and
if you're the New York Times it goes up
by a lot so I mean
um I think there's work that independent
journalists can do uniquely that
they can actually take like in some ways
more risk than a giant institution which
has a lot more in my sense to lose even
though it would appear like they have
more in terms of Defense too but you get
uh you can be bullied legally yeah do
you get afraid of that sure I mean
I just uh
all these things are things you have to
be aware of and then forget to do your
job like you have to be you know it's
like it's like being like a snowboarder
and it's like do you realize you could
hit your head and it's like yeah of
course but in order to go do the like
the flip or whatever you have to just
accept the risk
mitigate the risk as much as possible
and move on so we have
um we have like insurance we keep like a
pool of funds for that kind of thing
like I'm very conservative with how I I
spend my money basically all on
production and like trying to make my
life as secure as I can and then I just
do the work that I you know I I want to
do